welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of
invincible season 2 episode 1 on Amazon
Prime video and this video is sponsored
by Squarespace the all-in-one platform
that makes launching your own website a
breeze we are back covering this amazing
series episode by episode for all the
Easter eggs animation details deeper
layers of meaning that you might have
missed I love this show it's honestly
one of the best superhero adaptations
that is on TV right now so we're going
to break down every episode of this
season it's going to be a lot of fun all
right we open this season on a desolate
terrain as one hole is blown open in a
cloud followed by another for a second
we assume we are back in another aerial
battle between invincible and omn man
but no these holes are actually for
telling other portals through the
Multiverse that this season premiere
will take us through as these are
actually blown open by Sonic blasts from
Invincible battling the immortal whom we
last saw in the season 1 Kaiju Battle
bisected by omn man but his remains were
gathered by the GDA with the intent to
resurrect him but that never happened to
this Immortal because we are in an
alternate reality as a dark version of
Mark quips I've been hit harder before
like way harder so arrogant just like
your father as they fight Mark asks
Immortal to trust him after what omn man
did after what you did so this Mark has
been in the past beaten bloody by omn
man he just had a different reaction to
it later angstrom Levy explains that in
most other dimensions the battle ends
with Mark and omn man teaming up so it
tells us that in the one dimension that
we have been following there's something
unique about this Mark and I think we're
going to find out what that thing is
this season while immortal fights midair
mostly with punches Mark begins to use
kicks and knee attacks rolling kicks
more and more but Immortal gets wise to
this and chokes him but omn man swoops
down slicing through immortal's arms so
precisely that he leaves Mark untouched
but the immortal tries to apply some of
the lessons he learned from fighting
Mark using lower body attacks against
omn man but it doesn't work his other
harm gets snapped and omn man beheads
him and Mark savagely crushes his skull
yeah for anyone just tuning into this
season not knowing what the show is it
gets bloody like this and and it's just
so unsettling to hear Steven yun's
cheery voice delivering a cold
oppressive recorded message he says
people of Earth as in he no longer
identifies with his human half only his
paternal Vite lineage he says the more
you resist the worse this
gets we didn't destroy your cities you
destroyed them by fighting back a hooded
figure walks up to the massive video
screen and if you still think you can
stop us don't forget I'm
[Music]
Invincible ooh the fact that we don't
cut to the title text of the word
Invincible we hear him say it in context
it just tells us that we are in kind of
a backwards bizarre world and I love how
this episode keeps giving us little fake
outs of the word Invincible like that it
waits to do this until a precise moment
but the imagery here of a small figure
in front of a large big brother and
Screen seems inspired by the famous 1984
Apple Macintosh Big Brother Super Bowl
commercial where a revolutionary figure
charges up to a screen of big brother
and smashes it with a Sledgehammer this
hooded guy is angstrom Levy voiced by
Sterling K Brown and this episode is
kind of his origin story even though
he's been pretty busy up until this
point angstrom takes a hidden entrance
to a school bus to an underground Subway
tunnel where we can see train cars have
been turned into housing units alongside
a bunch of tents and the track Wells are
filled with these glowing green Rivers
we are reminded of the train station
where the most brutal Carnage took place
in Mark and Nolan's fight in the season
1 finale Levy meets up with robot with
his original Rudolph Connor's body in a
mobile suit back in season 1 this
original body died during the cloning
process with mer twins before Connors
cloned himself using Rex's DNA to become
the young Rudy Connors but this
universe's version of Adam Eve indicates
Rex died the immortal LED them away
we're safe
yeah that's what Rex thought too we see
how Eve has a shaved head and scars on
her face which sounds like they were
given to her by Mark hey Eve you look
good this whole idea of a dystopian
Society with superheroes being hunted
down while one of them uses portals to
escape failure after failure Rec calls
the opening to 2014's X-Men Days of
Future Past one of the best X-Men films
to date in my opinion the best depiction
of time travel in a Marvel movie and I
say Marvel movie because Loki the series
is the best version of it but like
Avengers end games time travel logic was
all over the place the nextmen days of
future past is a really good time travel
movie that uses Consciousness
displacement but it's a movie everyone
sleeps on because you know it defies the
narrative that from 2012 onward the MCU
dominated everything Marvel but it's not
true 2014's Days of Future Past 2016's
Deadpool and 2017's Logan were better
than like 90% of MCU movies I don't care
what anyone says bite me on it and yes
well you can say that angram Levy is
ripping off what the MCU is doing with
jonath the majors as Kang someone who
has gone to war with his variants this
depiction of Anam Ley actually comes
from Invincible Comics that predated
what the MCU is doing with this version
of Kang like Kang as a character in the
Marvel Comics emerged in the 60s but
they didn't have this particular take of
every incarnation of Kang being variance
of one conqueror until like the late
'90s and it still didn't really even
make sense I would say until the
Avengers unleash storyline in 2017 like
if Marvel wants to move away from Kang I
won't be too upset because Kang as a
character is just kind of like a mess
give us Dr Doom anyway so omnian
actually uses the same attack combo on
robot that he used on the immortal slice
the arm lacerate the whole body lacerate
the center part of the body either the
neck or the Torso Levy acquired a
canister of what they're calling null
energy that robot blasts at omn man
releasing this purple colored glow with
a dark interior visually similar to the
dark saber of Star Wars but it's a cool
way of showing antimatter of energy that
defies the principles of nature because
it's like negative colors right they
hope it's going to be a kind of
cryptonite for omn man but it doesn't
work omn man smashes Connor's pod
through a crowd of people and it creates
a pool of their blood and he says
someday you too will die sure but you
should have died at Birth oof his fluid
leaks out like tears now amyan comes
from a Spartan esque Vite society that
never would have allowed being born with
genetic deformities to live Mark cracks
Eve's neck but it's even worse than we
thought she's not dead just paralyzed
huh so that's what you were practicing
on those protesters last week oh my God
yeah Mark signals that he has people who
can take care of Eve what does that mean
it's just horrifying that his goal now
is to keep people alive but paralyzed
for experimenting on for interrogation
for who knows what Levy drops through a
portal to escape and how little omn man
cares about this Escape should signal to
us how vulnerable vites are to Universal
Tech like they're completely unaware of
it or that he fully knows what it is and
doesn't care because he can kill
everyone anyway so we cut back to our
Mark in our universe revisiting The
Cliffs side spot omn man pounded blood
out of him in season 1 his blood is
still on the Rock it's been about a
month and still it's there radio head's
Karma Police plays over this and while
creep is many people's go to radio head
track I think Karma Police is a better
song It's a song about stress carrying
guilt after doing something wrong and
just feeling that everyone is looking at
you sideways that Karma's going to get
you like the chorus is this is what
you'll get when you mad mess with us and
I like how this both frames Mark as the
Karma Police but really he is doing this
policing to Stave off the real Karma
Police that he feels like is bearing
down on him he's on this kind of penet
Montage going rogue to do good deeds he
sores past this woman in a headscarf
remember we saw this woman's alternate
universe self in the opening sequence
helping a man to his feet he stops the
villain elephant elephant appeared in
season 1 episode 5 and yeah having a
loose trunk it's kind of like having a
cape it's just kind of a liability that
your combatants can grab on to and
around Mark stops an armed chase this
time we don't even see Mark do anything
the engine just kind of disappears and
the pieces fall at their feet from above
it's kind of like this and then his
transporting that ambulance Mark does
not want to be seen he doesn't want the
credit he's just doing this for himself
he's wrestling with an invisible force
of karma he's not even doing it for
validation the bank robbers are tether
Tyrant and mag Maniac we saw them both
in season 1 episode 5 when they worked
for Machine Head and they fought Mark
and the Teen team Mark quickly though
flashes back to the season one finale
when he was smashed through that subway
car as he was bathed in Blood and Guts
and he's like you know what let the
police and the GDA forces handle it so
Mark flies home while his mother Debbie
watches a news report about Chicago
rebuilding after omn man's attack and
across the street we see a crater left
by omn man destroying the house that the
GDA was using to monitor him this is
where he killed Donald Ferguson by
crushing his spine so the destruction
that Nolan caused wasn't just in the
urban center it is literally outside
their front door a desert lizard crawls
up to a bone in the sand above the GDA
prison facility it kind of looks like a
human femur so presumably these laser
have fried past individuals escaping or
individuals trying to Spring others free
this is where the mer Twins were locked
up at the end of season 1 and we catch
up with them here they harass their
guard Pete about the quality of the food
this is the same guard whose arm they
broke when they escaped in season 1
episode 3 and later in episode 8 we see
the guy still had to show up to work
despite his injuries and another cell
further down the line are these guys
this is multi paaul duplicates younger
twin brother we saw him in season 1
episode 3 back when there were far more
than four of them locked up and we're
still not sure why they're in prison
though big holiday feast aren't just
about what's on the table they're about
the whole experience the company the
decorations the vibe for lack of a
better word running an online business
is similar offering a quality product
isn't enough you want to make sure
things are just right and for that
there's Squarespace Squarespace is an
all-in-one platform that provides you
with everything you need to do whatever
you need with your website Squarespace
has templates and designs for pretty
much everything so even if you're making
your very first website using
Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update content and
add features to fit your unique needs
for instance Squarespace makes it easy
to sell merch you can design your
products then save time and money by
letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping and if you're
selling any other kind of physical Goods
digital Goods or even a service
Squarespace makes it easy to build your
storefront and grow your business to
check it out for yourself head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rock stars to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain the MERS go through Le portals
to another Universe where this prison is
in a crater and one steps on the charred
skeleton of a GDA agent and here in this
Dimension the same green lizard crawls
around the MERS deduce that angstrom
needed a crater deep enough to extract
them from their Subterranean prison in
the original universe and that tells us
that whenever a portal is open across
Universe it's in the same exact spot and
three-dimensional space on that planet
so that would mean when angstrom dropped
out of his portal in the opening scene
it was too a reality where there is an
even deeper underground hideout we go
back to Reginal Ville Johnson High
School named after Reginal Ville Johnson
the actor from Family Matters in Die
Hard who voices the principal on the
show and we'll come back to voice the
principal this season everyone in the
hallway stares at Mark and even though
we don't hear Karma Police here that is
what Karma Police is about but they
don't know he's Invincible or what he
has really gone through they just think
that his father Nolan died and the bully
Todd who fought Mark in the series pilot
he returns here but just a hug Mark to
prove he's not an we saw
something similar with Flash Thompson
and Peter Parker after Uncle Ben died in
the 2012 The Amazing Spider-Man Amber
tries to console Mark and Mark meets up
with Cil at Burger Mart where he worked
in season 1 Cil though refused to put
mark back in field so soon you can't
stop me I don't need your permission to
be a superhero you know who else said
that to me back at the Pentagon we see
the parking in rear sign as we saw in
the first season it's a bit taken
directly from the comics ceso talks with
Donald Ferguson who was killed by omn
man but in the comics this character is
a robot so perhaps they're doing
something similar here kind of like with
Agent Coulson returning an agents The
Shield after Loki stabbed in the back in
Avengers 2012 at first it was revealed a
result of project Tahiti and later
Coulson returned as a life model decoy
version of himself Ferguson says they
could really
use Invincible yeah he pauses before he
says it like even in this universe
there's still playing this little game
with us a viewer the city is being
terrorized by the giant who's a red
skinned Kaiju from the Invincible comics
who's really an 8-year-old who just fell
through a dimensional portal with his
grandmother and got Enchanted by a cruel
wizard that's why he's stupid and angry
and wants to be both president and a
astronaut Rex duplicate monster girl
shrinking Ray black Samson and robot his
new body inside of the robot shell a
body cloned from Rex's DNA they all
struggle to deal with a threat that
should be pretty easy to handle Rudy
realizes there's a parking garage
beneath the Giant and sets demo charges
that Rex ends up having to blow up so
again we see the solution to the problem
in this episode is always to go even
deeper angstrom shows the MERS what he's
been building that's one of our sematic
encoders but bigger I based it off your
design it reads copies and writes human
minds and angstrom explains there's an
infinite number of dimensions and I was
born with the ability to access all of
them yes in these green portals you can
see what looks like the ruins of a
cityscape from the opening scene and
then another what some kind of like
ancient ruins that look like a Salvador
Del painting he goes on all our problems
famine War climate change cancer have
been solved somewhere else yeah notice
how he singles out famine War climate
change cancer these are the same kind of
problems that Mark in the other Universe
posed the people of Earth promising that
VTR could solve it's like we're getting
two sources of power from off Earth
making the same kind of Devil's bargain
angstrom says and I can be the conduit
of that knowledge a Prometheus who
raises the bar for Everyone by sharing
what works yes Prometheus the Titan from
Greek mythology who stole fire from the
gods to give the first Spark of
technology to mankind but what he
forgets about that mythological story is
that Prometheus was tortured for his
theft for all eternity angstrom Reveals
His safe house is filled with dozens of
alternate selves including some who are
women and one who has three eyes and
four arms on his torso since he just
wants to take their knowledge of their
home dimensions and not share his vision
of putting it all together we get the
sense that angstrom is somewhat
dishonest kind of a ends justify the
means typee of guy Olga waits for Debbie
with a knife making stenov and Debbie at
first thinks she's there to hurt her due
to omn man killing red rush so she is
also haunted by the Karma Police Debbie
recalls Rome having good pizza before
realizing Rome was a trip Nolan took her
on in season 1 the episode right before
she realized he killed the Guardians of
the globe by finding his blood covered
suit Debbie is still reeling from Nolan
saying she was just a pet to him and
that holding inside has been like acid
eating her away until she's Hollow and
when Mark comes home we see the kitchen
from his perspective that they have
multiple bottles of wine out and that
Debbie filled her glass all the way up
to the brim which is something that you
only do with wine after it's like your
fourth or fifth glass and you just stop
carrying how much you pour Cecil chews
out the heroes for their failure with
the giant saying it's a failure of
leadership from Rudy who has been
struggling with his new body in the
physiological fear that he cannot help
but Emmit Cecil assigns the resurrected
Immortal to take charge he also adds to
the team bulletproof who's voiced by Jay
Pharaoh in the comics bulletproof AKA
zandali Randol actually takes up the
mantle of invincible at one point we'll
see what happens with this Mark worries
to Eve that he could become his dad and
not even know it see that's the fear not
making the wrong ethical choice but not
knowing whether the choice has already
been made for you or not Mark offers to
help Cecil right when they realize the
Mer's Warehouse energy levels have gone
off the charts so on angst's machine you
can actually see one of his variants is
tattered clothes and bionic Parts like
maybe a Survivor from some futuristic
War reality the MERS say that this
machine is connecting to the nine other
machines in other dimensions so there
are 10 of them in total and they say a
th000 mines are synced that would mean
100 variants per machine it's just
interesting that the number is a
thousand according to books like Malcolm
gladwell's a Tipping Point the human
mind can only occupy 150 other
personalities names identities in their
head at any given time in Fortune 500
companies apply this to how they grow
and scale their businesses that anytime
you have more than 150 people working in
a workspace it's time to build another
Branch so having 1,000 Minds in your
mind forced in there at any given time
would make you crazy our angstrom says I
am large and and I
contain
multitudes yes this is a quote from a
Walt Whitman poem Song of Myself section
51 the full passage goes do I contradict
myself very well then I contradict
myself I am large I contain multitudes
the idea that people in their thoughts
can evolve and change and even though we
might have internal contradictions it is
the sum of all of our experiences that
help us make choices angstrom is now
grappling with the multitudes of 1,000
versions of himself flooding into his
mind Mark arrives and the MERS say no
way way he lives up to his name he's
definitely not Invincible again they are
toy with the convention of using the
word in context versus cutting to the
title card when will they do it it's
coming up soon angstrom calls in some
backup MERS from other dimensions who
have been helping as well our MERS are
not happy to see that after all they
already argue over who is the Clone and
who is the original among the two of
them they have trust issues you were
using other uses you said we were
special the MERS from other dimensions
have different outfits there's a version
with masks and some sort of turtle shell
on the back a mer with a beard at
cybernetic parts and at least one female
She-Hulk style mer Mark tries to use his
speed to subdue them but their strength
is too much and it becomes a literal
blood bath I won't build my Utopia with
blood but the thing is assuming Mark
is the MERS would make him bleed and
bleed but you know he might not actually
die so angstrom is kind of making this
choice for the wrong reason he takes off
his headpiece and the Machine explodes
and in the flames you can see the Mer's
bodies in incinerating down to their
skeletons only Mark is left and when the
EUR host show up Rex says huh I guess he
really is Invincible not yet Mark comes
home and the two wine bottles that were
on the counter the night before are now
open and empty and Debbie's glass is
spilled on the counter you know not that
Debbie doesn't have a reason to drink
but you know there's a lot of red flags
here let's keep an eye on it Amber and
Mark open their letters from Upstate
University at the same time remember
this is a campus they tored in season 1
and they both get accepted Immortal
tells Mark Cecil thinks you're on our
side
di I'm not so sure ah the Karma Police
is now literalized with a watchdog who
seems to be able to see into Mark's soul
and we leave it there until the
post-edit scene where deformed merer
discovers angstrom it made me a freak he
killed so many people I knew people I
loved Millions died because of him yeah
mer says that Ang's memories are all
scrambled but angstrom says they are all
his memories and that he wants revenge I
won't rest until I've killed
[Music]
and as that blood gets wiped away a
crack forms in the word invincible so we
learned this episode was an origin story
for angstrom Levy who did first appear
in Invincible Comics number 16 and he
was a multiversal figure and I just love
how this angstrom cannot assign victim
or perpetrator roles because he just has
too many memories too many identities
scrambled together in his mind and this
was not Mark's doing it was angstroms
own fault and it was his own empathy
that did it so when he realizes that
empathy was the culprit here he's kind
of like Kate blanch head from Crystal
Skull if her head didn't explode he's
put himself on a path to kill someone
who literally cannot be killed at least
I don't think so Invincible doesn't fear
death anymore he fears what he might
become I'm so excited to break down
every episode of this season please
support new rockstars by grabbing one of
these Loki inspired shirts from nerd
riot. shop if you live in the LA area be
sure to grab some tickets for our live
show on November 16th big thanks to Eric
auu Eric Francisco and Brandon barck for
helping me write this breakdown
subscribe to all three of the channels
in the St Network you can follow me at
eaos thanks for watching I'll see you
next time
[Music]
bye